بس تطلعي راي بريء العالم قال كلمتهم
بصراحه وعلى الملا لا لهم ماسك الذي اثار
باستراتيجيته المعتاده الجدله مجددا عندما
سال المستخدمين هل تريدونني ان اتنازل عن
منصبي سؤال بريء اليس كذلك حسنا ليس تماما
عندما يطرح ايلين ماسك هكذا استفتاء فهو
يعرف نتيجه مسبقا واتخذ قراره قبل طرحه
ثم ملايين شخص قالوا لملك تويتر تنازل عن
منصبك في استفتاء رسم نهايه رئاسه ماسك
التنفيذيه للمنصه الشهيره بعد استحوا به
عليها قبل شهرين فقط لفتره وصفات بعرض
السيرك بدات بهذه التغريده لهذاليه ودفاع
على اثرها 44 مليار دولار للاستحواذ على
المنصه
ولكن هذا ليس الاستفتاء الوحيد الذي اجره
ماسك على تويتر فمن منا لا يتذكر استطلاع
راي اعاده حساب ترامب على المنصه او اخر
استطلاع حول اعاده حسابات الصحفيين الذين
اثار غضب رائد الاعمال الشهير الذي اجرى
جمله من التغييرات من تسريح نحو نصف
العاملين وفضل رسوم مقابل وضع علامه
التحقق الزرقاء قبل ان تتوقف المحاوله
ليعود الامر الى سابق عهده قبل اسبوع
[تصفيق]
العالم الان بانتظار الاعلان عن الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد لتويتر بعد اشهر قليله
ولكنه وصفت بالصعبه لماسك وتويتر
ولمستخدميه تويتر وبانتظار الاعلان عن
سياسه واستراتيجيات جديده قد لا تكون
بالضروره مثيره للجدل كما اعتدنا مؤخرا
لصباح العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن